i'm sean o'shea in eastern ukraine we're
only about 12 kilometers from
russian-held territories and it is in
those territories that human rights
watchers say
thousands maybe 6 000 ukrainian
prisoners are being held mostly soldiers
but also civilians and human rights
watchers also say a large number of
those who are in captivity right now
have been tortured global news spoke to
one prisoner who was released in a
prisoner exchange he said that electric
shock was used by interrogators and
frequently he said it was not being used
for the purposes of getting information
just for pleasure now russia provides
very little information about prisoners
and doesn't distinguish between
civilians and soldiers by contrast
ukrainians holding russians
talk about living conditions and they do
provide red cross and other people to
visit them but people here in spite of
what is going on say they're going to
vow to keep on fighting i want canadians
to know that we
will resist
and we will fight until
the
our win
until we defeat this evil
and as for that prisoner we spoke to he
says once he recovers from his injuries
he would like to go back to the front
lines to continue to defend his country
sean shea global news in northeast
ukraine